bonjour et merci d'être avec nous alors
le premier ministre devra s'expliquer
devant les députés sur la mise en place
du déconfinement au printemps dernier et
sur sa gestion actuelle de la crise
selon vous à titre d confiné trop tôt
est ce que c'est pour cela qu'on est de
nouveau re confiné bonjour écoutez on
est là dans le cadre de décisions
politiques qui ont été prises en
fonction d'une situation sanitaire
bon vous savez moi je suis médecin alors
je sais juste mon avis et en aucun cas
c'est la vérité absolue
je pense que donc si on me demande juste
mon avis à moi je crois que l'eau
déconfinement il fallait le faire bien
sûr
après je pense que l'exécutif a péché
par manque d'information par manque de
pédagogie
la société n'a pas pu prendre conscience
des enjeux réels des mesures à
comprendre et assimiler des lots
déconfinement ce qui aurait permis de
passer un été différent tout en tout en
s'assurant quand même que le tourisme
pouvait vivre mais surtout qu'on aurait
finalement des français bien au clair à
partir de septembre est en fait on voit
bien qu'il ya eu le déconfinement un peu
brut et que très vite c'est un peu
binaire et moi même à l'époque n'était
pas la réflexion je m'étais d'iskandar
de passer du déconfinement adobe
confinement adéquat finement sans
finalement un ensemble de mesures de
pédagogie et vous voyez ce qui se passe
en fait il ya un gros problème de
communication je pense qu'il est un gros
problème de coordination des mesures qui
sont prises sert comprend des mesures
dont les explique après c'est comme
gabriel attal ce matin serre qu'il
évoque un couvre-feu à paris et puis en
fait on se rend compte que matignon dit
bah non c'est pas tout de suite ça donne
un effet un peu de brouillon et le
message envoyé aux français il est pas
bon parce que les français ont besoin de
sentir que lors les patrons un ceux qui
s'occupent du pays ça où ils vont et en
fait à chaque fois qu'il ya des prises
de parole comme ça c'est compliqué alors
moi je voudrais juste dire que
concernant
jean castex et l'audition on est on est
là on est là en plein dans la deuxième
vague
la deuxième crise moi moi je veux bien
qu'ils aient des auditions sur le
premier déconfinement mais je
préférerais vraiment que les
parlementaires travaillent aujourd'hui
pour réfléchir à relancer l'économie
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'en fait toutes les mesures qu'on
entend aujourd'hui dans la presse et
dans les médias vont faire les ventes
sur façon quand on ferme les petits
commerces
j'aimerais que donc il ya beaucoup
d'énergie qui sont dépensés pour
informer la population sur les
interdictions et les diminutions de
liberté nécessaire rendue nécessaire par
l'insuffisance du soin en france donc en
fait j'aimerais que les parlementaires
plutôt que de lui on aura le temps plus
tard on aura le temps plus tard mais là
là il faut réfléchir aux solutions
comment faire pour maintenir l'économie
il faut tout repenser il faut être
ingénieux il faut demander aux gens de
continuer à travailler sans exposer la
société un risque sanitaire élevé pour
ça il faut réfléchir il faut des idées
moi j mais en fait je voulais tant qu'on
temps qu'on abordera le fonctionnement
de la société tel qu'on le connaissait
avant ça ne marchera jamais et la
conclusion c'est qu'on enferme les gens
c'est pas possible vous voyez il faut
faire de la communication auprès des
jeunes j'ai vu rémy salomon qu'à
proposer des vidéos courtes c'est une
excellente idée
il faut demander aux entreprises quelles
sont leurs plans pour continuer à
produire à produire à produire tout en
faisant en sorte que l'on ne prenne pas
de péril sanitaire
peut-être qu'il faut décaler les
horaires peut-être il faut bosser la
nuit peut-être qu'il faut bosser la nuit
tout simplement peut-être qu'il faut
inverser tout il faut tout repenser pour
permettre deux ans pour essayer de
limiter la casse économique
et bien sûr tout cela tout en expliquant
aux français ce qu'on fait pour l'heure
soit c'est à dire on sait qu'ils
manquent de place en réanimation
on sait qu'il manque de lits est ce
qu'on a mis en place les brigades de
réanimation pour renforcer les services
non c'est toujours pas fait est-ce qu'on
a mobilisé tous les hôtels de france
pour aller mettre des malades dans les
hôtels ce n'est toujours pas fait est-ce
qu'on a est ce qu'on a mis en place dans
toutes les écoles les ehpad la maison de
retraite les hôpitaux des purificateurs
d'air moi j'ai passé ma soirée hier au
téléphone avec des industriels qu'en
fait qu'ils font des purificateurs d'air
commis un peu en allemagne s'est déjà
closes
unis est ce qu on a mis ça en place
est-ce qu'on a est ce qu'on a préparé
des vidéos dudit courte et choc a
diffusé sur tous les réseaux sociaux
type toc sna chat
là où il ya les jeunes pour expliquer ce
qui va se passer aux mains de
déconfinement est ce qu'on donne aux
français l'impression qu'on fait tout
pour que noël puisse peut-être se vivre
en famille
il faut donner un peu d'espoir aux
français même si cette submersion du coc
vide elle est plus forte que nous et et
qu'elles mettent tout en péril
il faut quand même que là maintenant on
sorte des schémas habituels de premier
ministre de la santé porte-parole
puisque de toute façon ça marche pas
donc en fait il faut une cellule de
crise qu vide en france
je pensais ce matin que par exemple il
serait très intelligent de d'inventer
dans chaque municipalité un un immeuble
locaux vides un lieu cosy d' une sorte
de deux dispensaires covit dans lequel
les soignants pourrait venir chercher
leur matériel dans lequel il pourrait
être informé de tous les protocoles en
place dans lequel on pouvait faire de la
prévention d'éducation
ces bâtiments la pomme pourrait être
éco-responsable ça ça ferait fabriquer
des ça ferait à ça ferait travailler des
gens vous voyez il faut tout revoir
mais mais mais mais mais il faut avoir
comme obsession de soigner les gens le
plus possible parce que manifestement la
société a pas encore décidé de trier les
patients et de laisser mourir nos aînés
donc il faut renforcer le soin il faut
faire un sig sûrs d'eux je suis
responsable d'un collectif qui le
demande depuis trois mois
aujourd'hui le problème madame quand on
parle du coc vide on parle du manque de
paramédicaux je vous dis qu'avec le
ségur 2 vous mobiliserez plus de
paramédicaux c'est aussi simple que ça
il faut le faire il faut faire amende
honorable des erreurs passées il faut
faire un état des lieux des médecins
réanimateurs en france qui aujourd'hui
peut faire de l'animation on regarde le
stock co animateur et on les dispatche
partout ça aurait dû être fait en mars
aurait dû être préparé en mars pour la
deuxième crise parce que le problème
madame c'est que si l' on fait une
audition rice désolé trés rares gagnants
très rapidement on a vu beaucoup de
temps très rapidement le problème c'est
qu'à la vague 3 et la vague iv qui nous
attendent
donc si là on est en train de tirer les
conclusions de la vague il vous
comprenez bien qu'on est en décalage
total donc arrêter les eaux
sion a été travaillée trouver les
solutions pour faire en sorte que
l'économie passe pourquoi les
restaurateurs ne vont pas nourrir tous
les hôpitaux de france pourquoi les
les hôtels pourquoi on ne demande pas
aux entreprises de complètement changer
l'organisation les farbos et la nuit la
nuit peut être qu'à moins de risques je
sais rien ou alors la moitié le joint la
moitié là nous il faut maintenir cette
économie mais il faut l'organiser
autrement si on conserve les codes
habituels orco vide on n'y arrivera pas
locaux vides et là il va partir du jour
au lendemain
olivier leurent l'a bien dit aura
peut-être pas de vaccin cet été ce qu
vie de l'avarice mais nos vies donc
mince on est une espèce intelligente
alors on s'adapte mais il faut savoir à
un moment donné modifier les codes
habituels modifier les organisations
habituelles les français veulent vivre
ils veulent profiter leurs familles et
ils veulent compte ils ne veulent pas
faire faillite
donc en fait et ben si ça l'adage il
faut soigner tout le monde il faut que
personne ne fasse faillite et ombrelles
organise tout on a je pense les
capacités pour le faire en tout cas moi
j'ai plein d'idées
même si l'exécutif ne m'écoute pas en
tout cas moi j'ai plein d'idées arnaud 6
merci en tout cas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
les idées vos idées sont bien passées
sur notre antenne vous rappelle que vous
êtes anesthésiste réanimateur à
l'hôpital d'hénin beaumont et président
du collectif santé en danger
merci merci